Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier and welcome back to Diep.io!
Now admittedly, the last episode that I played of this, I wasn't 100% very good at the game.
It was like my second time playing ever. But I've gotten a lot more practice lately -
And I'm gonna show you my fairly foolproof plan of epicness and awesomeness
that's gonna get you to the #1 on the leaderboard!
Guaranteed or your money back! Only 2,999 payments of 299 dollars!
...Alright. So, basically, when you're starting up the game, uh, it goes pretty simply.
And you guys actually told me that I was incredibly stupid.
Which, admittedly, isn't much different than what you guys normally tell me.
What you guys nicely told me was that bullet penetration actually is incredibly useful
because it's kind of a damage booster,
as well as the ability to fight through multiple objects and multiple bullets, and be able to
beat other players, because you can actually get your bullets, through THEIR bullets.
Which is very important because if you're, uh, getting into the end game
and you actually are trying beat someone, you NEED to be able to bash through their wall of bullets
before you can get anywhere, or else you will have no progress being done!
So, when you're starting out, same thing when you're starting out it's pretty -generic- .
It's pretty much simplistic in what you're doing, you do the basic stuff, you do this, you avoid that...
... you try not to get killed by that guy...
And, what I found is to be the easiest, not always the most exciting,
but the easiest is just to go the machine gun route,
and then go for gunner afterwards, because
the spray of bullets combined with a lot of bullet speed can definitely get you going, like..
..i-it can surprise people, so long as you can ambush people.
Because most of the big people that you see on leaderboards
will usually be one of the triangle ones.
And that's great for covering a lot of options and getting a lot of, uh,
getting a lot of object kills,
which is good, because that does get points eventually, but...
What you're gonna want, uh, down the road is the ability to:
1. Shoot while running-
Oh man, there's some lag on this server, but you wanna be able to shoot while running..
And then, uh, you wanna be able to, quickly hit-and-run people without giving them too much of your time.
Be careful out there looking for mods right now,
because there- I don't think there's any official mod place,
so, anything that you might find that may give you a seemingly unfair advantage
might actually just be viruses, so watch out for that definitely.
Watch out for k-
WOOOAAAHH! Fhahahuck...
I am a fucking fool! Fuuuuck me!
Competition seems to be kinda fierce on this map.
I'm not gonna lie, I can't seem to get an escape.
I imagine over on the right side, I might get a little more solace.
But I gotta get over there is the thing.
Wo-oah! That guy's going nuts!
Alexis, calm down! It's not that important, it's just a vidya game!
Ok, so I'm on the other side of the map,
but I have a funny feeling that it's not gonna be any better than where I was before,
I'm gonna be in a similar situation.
Woah! Hey! It's a swarm.
No! Don't do it! No!
No! No no no! No no!
No! No no no! No. Don't
Don't. I don't wanna mess with you, you don't wanna mess with me,
I-we'll kill each other, it won't be good for anybody.
[Mutters] As long as I can get out of the way of -your- bullets.
Come on, come on, you wanna fight?
Yes! Got him. Ok, so, gunner is the next upgrade that I generally do.
Uuuuhhhhhh...
bullet speed.
Ok, because it just allows you to absolutely bombard people, just like THAT, and then destroy them..
and, I'm kind of in a corner here.
The thing is, you will recuperate health if you wait long enough,
but you just need to be able to WAIT long enough
so that your uh, health goes back up to 100%.
Because after a while, I mean health regen is one thing, but that's in-combat health regen.
What you want, is you want to be able to just, smash and MOOOVE as fast as you can!
See, like that! It just regenerates all the way up to full...after a while.
Get my health up...
No way bro! Nah, too late bruh, sorry.
Couldn't do anything for you, bruh.
Just the way it is, bruh.
Nothing I can do.
Woah, shit!
There's a lot of battles for supremacy going on here!
Wooap?
Wooapem! Got 'em.
Oh, why didn't I get points for that?
Nyeh shit.
Ok, so what I'm gonna do now is I'm gonna try to..
I'm gonna try to mooove towards... the center of the map,
even though I'm not at the center at the moment.
*ho*
We're almost max level, so the most important thing now is just to stay alive.
I am on the leaderboard,
but I'm only a lowly number six,
compared to number 1 who has 150,000 points.
But that's just because if you get number 1, after a while you can just sit in the middle
and then enjoy the, the fruits of your labor
which is just all of the, uh, octagonals, in the center of the map.
Pentagonals.
Aah! It's, it's gunner on gunner action!
Who's gonna win? I think me!
I think me!
Oh shit.
Maybe not me.
HA HA! IT WAS ME-HE-HE! [Triumphant laugh]
Ok, so I'm gonna get, uh, full-on bullet speed because,
just to be able to chase people down with my bullets
is super duper important!
Alright, how about I just spray in this general area and you're probably dead.
That's what I imagine.
Ok, so I'm number 1...
Ah uh, not number 1, I'm not number 1 I'm number 4.
But those are the giant ones that I was telling you guys about.
They're really hard to kill, so it's hard to get the last hit on it
because only the last hit gives you points...
kind of a, League of Legends style.
Noooooo.
And these little bastards will try to hunt you down,
and then they got their big momma bastards that are also a part of it.
But, nothing to worry about!
Nothing to worry about.
'Cuz, the other thing about a gunner is that it's very easy to get last hit on something like that,
because of how many bullets you put out.
So long as you can keep the pressure on, then you should be able to do something 'good'.
Nonononono. Mine.
What the frick? What'd you think you're doing, buddy?
Yeah that guy, that guy is uhhhh...
probably can't win against me because of the distribution of his bullets.
Besides, compared to the focus of mine,
and the distribution of his...
Like, it's obvious which one of us will win and that's why he's running away like a lil' baby.
HE'S BEWARING THE MARKIFART!
It's a little easier though just to go for all the pentagons, cause there's just oodles of them.
And oodles of them! There's an OODLES of them!
They-there's more fighters the more uh, of these pentagons come in.
What are they? Pentagon, pentagons, yeah, pentagons.
PenTAgonal. Pen-pentaGOnal. Pe-Pen-Penty!
FIVE! FIVE-SIDED GEOMETRIC SHAPES!
Is what I'm talking about! And what I want!
OOOH I'm number 1! How did I get number 1? Ohh, the number 1 guy must've died.
But see, it's just THAT easy to get number 1,
when you just get oodles and oodles of all the points that you could possibly want,
and then you're able to kill people with reckless abandon whenever you get confronted by them.
I'm just a lonely Markifart!
What do you want from ME??
Uh oh. We got another. We got another ANGELR!
The guys that are so scared they just shoot out of every orifice on their body and hope for the beeest!
COME OVER HERE!
YOU WANNA MESS WITH THE MARKIFART?
NOBODY WANTS TO MESS WITH THE MARKIFART!!
[Random grunt]
I used to be Triple Dick Rick, but then I- I hung up that lifestyle because it wasn't working out for me
and then I- I went through a more reasonable aspect.
Which was... not that.
Woah, it's get-
I'll let them duke it out! I'll let them duke it out,
even though Alexis is getting a lot of points and I'm not TOO keen on that!
I should come in there but with two of them, they cover so much of the area
that it's very hard to make sure that I actually kill their bullets before they get to me.
Which I can do, I can definitely do, it's totally possible-
Yeah, that's right, Rob, you know who the best is!
You know who the best- Oh shit.
Fuck.
This is getting a lil' dense.
Lil' dense...
minemineminemineminemineMINE!
Hah ha hah ha!
And then Alexis, you gotta run away!
'Cause you can't handle the Markifart! Noone can!
I'm still number 1! Oh god, I gotta get out of here
because these fighters are just, messing me up so I'm gonna jus-
Oohhh shit, it's another gunner.
Woaah, no you don't (x4)!
The only thing scary is just, another gunner coming my way!
You came to the WRRROOONNG neighbourhood, Rodless! Ra-radleese? Re-laase?
Uh oh. Alexis is gunning for me.
Alexis is getting close! I don't like thaaat!
I kinda wanna just take care of Alexis but I don't have enough movement speed.
UUUHHHH IT'S HARD TO KEEP NUMBER 1 WHEN ALEXIS KEEPS COMING FOR ME!
And he won't come fight me, he's a big bubble-blowing baby
who's too SCARED to do anything! [lisping]
Uh oh.
It's a gunner battle!
Aaagh so many of 'em! AAAAH so many of em!
eugh shit.
euugghh shit.
NYAAH SHIT!
I got a lot of points, and I got a good lead over Alexis,
but I- I- I'm not- it's not cutting the mustard.
I need to like, go on the outskirts and kill some lower-level people
to be able to get a lot of points really quickly, or else I'm not gonna go anywhere.
Is that Alexis? Is that ALEXIS?
Where's the origin point of your BALLS, Alexis!?
Is that you A-LEX-IS?!
Or is that ROB tryna come up and steal glory?
So long as someone else takes these fighters,
like, I'm- I'm perfectly ok.
Whoah.
Oh, it IS ROB! Hi, ROB! How you doing, ROB?
Well... We're gonna have ourselves a good ol' time when-
[Singing] We're fighting togeeeethheerr... TOGEETHHEERR FOREVER!
[Singing] You can't run away from your fate,
Robby-Roooob!
Did I kill him? No. Yes? Did I?
YEAH-HAHA!
I killed him! YEAAH! Robby must've killed Alexis, and then I devastated everything.
I'm the best.
[Fake sobbing/laughter]
Yeah, there's some new sets of guns that I have't quite seen before like that one-
Holy shit, that's actually-
Really slow bullets though, so easy to avoid.
Don't even... WOAH! Hello.
I'm in a capable lead. I wanna get to 100,000.
And if I can get to 100,000 that will actually mean something to me!
I can engage and I can beat people
and then I can trounce them and then I can... make fun of their parents in front of them!
That's my only goal in life! To really humiliate everybody that I've ever beaten!
I do- I call this one the 'shimmy maneuver'!
If I see someone over in the distance that's shooting bullets but I can't quite see their body,
I just kinda shimmy my bullets all over the place until I get one eventually.
[Lisping] And that's my key to success!
[Singing] Shimmy shammy, shimmy shammy, flimmy flammy flimmy flammy,
shimmy shammy shimmy flammy flim!
[Singing] Don't even try you biiittcchh..
You wanna mess with meeeee..
You're gonna die real BAAADDDLYY!
[Normal tone] I'm not gonna lie, this guy who's taken over the center with no name seems to have a good morph,
or whatever the upgrade is.
I don't even know what it is, but it seems PLENTY powerful.
[Incomprehensible muttering]
Woah, hello Alexis! Welcome back, but unfortunately you're deeadd.
Come onnn... Yep! Got that one!
Ooh, 96,000! That's a lot of points!
This one's mine. You cannot beat me on this one.
No no no.
Did I get that?
FUCK YOU, dude!
You've took all my work! I will kill you.
I will destroy you and everything that you've ever built!
You wanna think that you're cool?
You're the opposite of that, it's true!
Just... imagine that I said that correctly and that you were intimidated by it..
I thought I might have had 'em and then lost 'em
but then it just turns out that I just didn't have 'em.
OHHH SHIIIITTT!
100,000, YEAAH! THE MARKIFART IS THE ULTIMATE DIEP!
DIE-EP!
DEEEEP-IO!
DEEEEEEEEEEP-IO!
So now that I got 100,000, I'm gonna play more aggressively
and I'm actually gonna chase after these sons of bitches
just as soon as I heal... (gasp)
'Cause I need health! I nee-
Hey, stop that! No, don't-
Aaah, who's a gunner over here?
Who's a gunner? Who's a gunning gunner?
I'll come after you as soon as I get my health back. But not a second sooner!
Alright, here we go. Coming for ya!
AAGHH, killer of world is... killer of now dead!
You're welcome, little guy who I helped!
I did that intentionally because I'm a hero, damnit!
TARTANS!
woop, woop woop WOOP!
WOOP? WOOP OOP OPPA GANGNAM STYLE!
Who's up HEEERRE?
HUH?!
Gonna give you all a fair shot at victory, but I don't think you're gonna get it!
Wuoooah!
'Spin = team'? How about SHOOT equals DEAD?
I like that option!
That's kind of my favourite at the moment!
Heh, like please no!
Man, he walked into death so quickly!
I didn't even get a chance to read his name!
(Loud gasp) TRIPLE DICK RICK!
OOH I USED TO BE YOU!
I used to want you..
Hang on, Markifart's soo-
Yeah, you wanna play, bruh?
You wanna play, bruh?!
YOU WANNA PLAY, BRUH?!
Come on, come on come on come on! AAAAH COME ON!
Dammit!
I want MOOORE! I need MOORE!
You thought you could run away and escape? The answer is...
... probably, because I can't seem to finish you off, 'cause I'm sooooo...
slow.
I'm just gonna shimmy and shammy until something dies!
RRRRRR! Did you die? Maybe?
I don't know. I don't see any more spray of bullets!
Ooh, is that you? Is that you, Dami-ohwn?!
Ooh, there you are!
Oh, sorry.
You- you got caught in the crossfire there. I'm after damien.
Ok. I got two people coming in on both sides! They better not be coordinating to sandwich me!
Because I don't like being part of a man-meat sandwich!
Exactly the opposite of what I enjoy!
How 'bout no? If you're spinning it doesn't make me wanna join your team!
I- I hate to break to you, but that's not how the world works.
You is kill? You want is kill??
HUH!? YOU WANT IS KILL?
YOU WANT IS KILL MAXXPOWER?
Oh fuck you, alexis. Don't, don't try to double team me, it won't work.
Well, it PROBABLY WILL WORK. But I'll blame LAG or SOMETHING!
You'll NEVER SEE... victory...!
Spray sporadically...
(GASP) I got him! I GOT HIM!
No, I didn't get him. No, that was something else, sorry.
I thought I got him. False alarm! It's totally cool.
But where did he go?
Oh! Doctor donut, I'm... so sorry... that it has to be like this.
I'm... very sorry doctor donut! I apologize sincerely!
You just cannot beat... THE MARKIFART!
Even gunner to gunner, you got the WRRONG UPGRADES!
I need to recover, though. I can't- I can't encounter anybody else.
Where the hell did MaxxPower go?!
If he wasn't- If he wasn't- If he didn't die, then where the hell did he go?
'Cause that doesn't make any sense!
Is that MaxxPower over there?
I don't know, man, I don't know!
[Mocking username] wdas woo?
wdas woo!
WADA WAS WOO?
WAD WAS WOO?!
WAD WAS WOO!?
wad was woo?
WAD WAS WOO!
WAD WAS WOO!!
This must be terrifying, just for someone to start shouting gibberish
into your ear as you're trying to murder 'em.
WAD WAS WOO!?
WWAAADD WAS WOO?!
Oh, hi Alexis, welcome back to the party!
I hate to break it to you again..
but death is upon yooou! YEEAAHH!
Alright, let's go in! Let's not play conservatively anymore!
Let's be aggressive..
Oh, there's WOD WAS WOO!
It's WAD WAS WOO!
OOH BUT THIS IS MINE!!
Oh shit. Ohh, shit.
Fuck, that guy was coming for me!
Oh shit, that guy does high damage.
Welp, it might be the end of my days, but I'm gonna try my best...
... to get this, and steal it, from him.
Did I? Did I? I don't know if I did.
It may have been, but I don't know.
Alright, this is getting very dicey, I think this is gonna be it!
I think this is gonna be the final battle! I'm gonna go out!
Aooh!- Oh shit, stole that kill!
Welp, final battle is... exploitative as always I've ever been!
Just, run in and steal other people's work.
And then, claim it as my own... [Sobs]
Hi Alexis! Hi!
Sorry, but your bullet stream is not as strong...
[Lisping] I see your swords is as big as mine...
Oh I gotcha! No? Yes? I don't know. I can never tell!
When the bullets just stop, I assume that someone's dead but that's not always the case.
That is unfortunate for him.
OOOOH YEESS! I almost had an upgrade!
I killed him so good, I almost got another upgrade point, did you see that?!
And I crossed 200,000!
YEEAAHH!
Oh man, I've never been this high up in score before so, I'm really happy about this!
Although, I feel like... I feel like I'm almost too dominant now.
No-one can stop the Markifart.
The Markifart has reached critical mass.
And now no-one can ever stop me!
[Gross inhale + Evil laughter]
Oh, I love it!
Winner get points!
More points than any one tank should have!
It's the prettiest thing in the wooorlld~
Man, I've just been reigning supreme for way too long. I feel bad at this point..
Like, I legitimately kinda feel like maybe I should,
MAYBE I should hang up my crown and give other people a chance.
Like sQUA over there.
Or No-name McDouble Gun!
Hey, sQUA! You wanna fight sQUA?!
Oh shit, sQUA might get me.
sQUA might get me. sQUA got me!
Ok..WELP, THAT IS ALLL WE WILL SAY ABOUT THAT!
I kind of let him win, but.. kind of I guess, I don't know I was kinda around playing at that point.
But thank you everybody so much for watching,
lemme see what you wanna see in the next video.
There's uh, team mode, and there's a new domination game mode available on this
and you can find it through the link in the description below.
Play it, it's totally free!
Thank you AGAIN and as always, I will see you in the next video...
BUH-BYE!
[Outro music: Crazy La Paint by MiniMusicMan]